hey guys it's the evident caitlyn
podcast the podcast that is your
official source for a 20-19 Holiday Gift
Guide fret for a and all guys it's just
it's just a guy it's just an official
[Laughter]
[Music]
alright so we just wanted to give you
guys a heads up that as we roll into
this holiday season we may skip a
podcast every now and then probably one
around Thanksgiving one around Christmas
and one around New Year's as we try to
like put a brakes on this like rolling
train that is evident Kaler but a breaks
on it people put our brakes on it so we
can like chill recuperate yeah a little
bit of a heads up that we're gonna
reduce the frequency but they will be
coming back in the new year
um today we still have like a couple
like we said we're still doing them you
know not everyone listens to every
podcast we'll probably give this heads
up in like a few oh yeah just in case
yeah it's may sound like we were taking
off between now in the New Year when you
said we'll come back in the new year
oh yeah yeah we're gonna be making more
podcast in the meantime but so alright
so today we're gonna be giving our
official Gift Guide and we're gonna be
doing it not in a normal style no cuz we
are not normal people making a game out
of it basically we got this idea because
we listen to the Tigers podcast and at
the end one of their like podcast like
the podcast coordinator his name is
Miles and he gives advice that will go
for miles with miles bonds in the re so
we kind of picked up a little bit of the
style from them so we want to give okay
so in this segment it's all just like
this bogus insane build-up for something
that's kind of like mundane advice
and he makes it up on the spot seemingly
I'm pretty sure you just mix it up on
the spot I think that he comes up with
it in advance really it's something that
sounds like like you see it pure chaos
yeah so it'll be like and it's very
maybe this podcast will be really
annoying if it's an entire podcast of us
doing the
voice but it's like do you wanna have
the skin of a tiny baby person do you
want to smell like a million flowers do
you want to meet your future spouse and
immediately win them over use shampoo I
was ready to go voice Dreiser but see
that that actually like illustrates the
game that we're gonna do we're gonna do
all of that lead up and then the other
person's gonna guess what the heck item
we're trying to hint at an item is the
gift yeah and I was for that olives
guessing lotion yeah I didn't really
know what so yeah I was like maybe it'll
be like a bath bomb or something and
then like I don't know what shampoo
popped in the way like your skin like a
baby's bottom yeah your head skin yeah
your head skin like smooth as a baby's
bottom yeah but your head skin that's
not a normal thing to think about
okay which is also what we're doing
we've not pre-prepared any of these um
clues yeah these these you know and they
can be kind of outrageous yeah so we'll
take turns
I think we have it broken down into like
stocking stuffer type gifts and unlike
regular gifts so we're walking stuffers
like small useful little things and then
we have like useful life normal everyday
stuff and then we have stuff for the
makers in your life yeah cuz I'm
guessing that a lot of you are makers
and you might know some makers so that
might be useful for you guys yes so how
about I'll start I'll give you the
category this is a maker related thing
okay do you wanna suck it's a shop vac
do you want to suck whatever you want to
it's a portable shot back yes oh my god
oh okay it's not just useful if you have
a workshop it is useful for all
everywhere for those of you guys who
don't know what a shop vac is
and how it's different from a vacuum
what a shopback does is there's a
container and there's a blower that
blows air out of that container and
creates a negative vacuum in that
container and their great thing about
that is the stuff that you're sucking
into the container doesn't necessarily
get spit out and it doesn't necessarily
touch the filter or the motor or
anything like that so what that means is
since it's creating a negative pressure
chamber you can suck up like wet things
you can suck up like big bigger things
you like it like it is this so much more
versatile than a normal vacuum and
having a portable shop vac for use
anywhere is amazing I'd say like it's
not just a maker tool it's just like an
amazing thing to have and the DeWalt one
that we have I looked it up it's still
one of the best rated ones out there
it's not sponsored by anyone by the way
these are just like products that we
have that we really enjoy yeah and we'll
link to like cuz we don't want to get
caught up in like oh it's the model
number so we'll just link to everything
in the show notes slash video
description yeah we'll probably link to
a blog post that has everything written
out organized with pictures we'll also
include a link in the show notes but
like go to the blog post it'll be better
yeah
not really but kind of okay it's hard
not
I probably should have gone down a less
obvious route with that one do you want
to be more organized than Marie Kondo
label maker
do you like tiny pieces of stickers with
tiny letters on them do you want to be
an organizational God then a label maker
okay
seriously I haven't got me our label
maker I don't even know what brand it is
like years ago years ago I I looked it
up I found a better version of it the
newer version of like the same thing it
has even more better reviews it has like
the best reviews I got it for her for
Christmas present and my family like
kind of chuckled and then I used it like
the most first but also that's part of
my gift to Caitlyn I was like this is
for you it's also for me to get
organized for you you might see them in
the background of our videos that we
keep like screws in and stuff like that
that way you don't just have like the
mismatched boxes of screws that would be
a good gift - it's a little bit more
expensive the drawer set is so great
it's so great oh great especially the
combination yeah it's just this wall of
lots of tiny drawers and so evan
labelled every single line it's so good
but like even in the closet that we
that's one of the projects we did
probably about a year ago where we
organized the closet in our office and
well there's oh there's so many drawers
in every single drawer every single
basket everything has a label on it and
it's just a life changing thing I think
especially like if if you're a maker or
if you're a crafter or even if you're
like just really into art you have a
bunch of art supplies like labeling your
supplies and keeping track of all that
stuff and being able like when you can
label things that means you can put
things in drawers and in boxes which are
easier to store on shelves and stack and
things like that and once you start
using it in new and different ways you
know it's like we have a lavell ear
wireless system and I labeled which one
was Caitlin's which one was mine which
like you know I like even write notes to
yourself for how to use things reminders
so that when you pick that thing up if
you always forget to do something you
can just put a sticker label right on it
on the computer that we use to record
this podcast that says audio test so
that we do an audio test recording or
like and there's a there's a bajillion
things once you have a label maker once
you have the power to label Evans got a
strip of label like a big label maker
strip I'm holding it up right now on his
Yeti that just says ever never never
never
I decided Evan I said maker and like how
to for to where we've chosen the same
products okay I'm gonna do something
that they think I wouldn't use but ya
know can you tell me are you gonna tell
me what category this is a stocking
stuffer for makers do you like screwing
things do you like tiny tools do you
want the power to build things get
weight can I get a so you said power
which makes me think powered but I was
thinking it was a handheld one is it
you're a little we're a little
ratcheting my tiny ratcheting yeah
quarter inch bit drop yeah it's so great
if you only have like if you if you're
building a really compact tool kit which
I have an obsession with I love putting
together Evan loves a go-bag like a tool
go bag and I love putting together the
most compact and versatile set of tools
it brings me joy and this is a great
instrument to have even if you have like
everything else you also need one of
these because there will come a time in
your making career where you need to
reach in to a very tight space and turn
mm-hmm a bolt and you will need this
very specific tool it's very flat it's
very small is very compact and it's
great for like reaching that odd little
screw they need to unscrew yeah and I've
used it many many many times I had one
in my bag for the longest time until I
tried to abuse it with a cheater and the
ratcheting system broke and so I just
got another one by that one that first
one lasted me like two years of use and
it's just a it's a very invaluable and
very small it
addition to your maker kit okay I want
to do something that like wouldn't be on
your list right I'm curious to see what
you think isn't on my list do you want
the face Oh tiny baby I know exactly
what it is do you wonder this the power
of the Sun the fairest of them all
scream I totally know like this is the
thing that like this is nothing I
recommend to literally and everyone
anyone who totally makes sense I have
been converted guys yeah kaylynn can
explain it from a point of expertise and
I'm gonna explain it from the lay
person's perspective
okay what's the lay person sunscreen is
gross
yeah in general we're talkin I'm
recommending is specifically for faces
where you really don't want gross stuff
on your face yeah it's thick it's greasy
I just don't like putting on sunscreen
in general no when I go to the beach
yeah kind of have to you know but like
there's a lot of reasons why you might
want to put sunscreen on daily if you
want to have a beautiful baby face your
whole life and Caitlyn has a beautiful
face not a baby face but like like her
skin is really like healthy and
everything and like it's very well
established that the Sun damages your
face so wearing sunscreen every day is
better for your face than not you should
do it yeah and the sunscreen that
Caitlyn is talking about is super it's
like it's like you're just rubbing water
on your face and it's not like greasy or
nasty or gross it's like a really late
quickly light very light quickly
absorbing face lotion that does not feel
or smell like sunscreen Ellen tell them
about the differences between UVA and
UVB this is my nan
I'm not real in spod cast ya words so so
I used to spend a lot of time on the
subreddit called skincare addiction and
this is where I learned everything but
basically there's like UVA UVB and UVC
rays and they do different things in
American sunscreens only like the
sunscreen rating system which is like
SPF is measuring the protection against
UVB which damages your skin in terms of
like cancer you can lead to scent skin
cancer yeah the way that like someone
explained it that helps me remember is
like UVB is like burning UVA is aging
like the effect they have slightly
different effects I know again I'm not
saying wrinkles your skin but but
anyways so SPF measures the UVB
protection and there's no like measuring
system in the US for UVA in other
countries like Japan where the sunscreen
is from there's a PA system so there's
like PA plus okay plus plus k plus L
sauce and PL plus plus plus there's four
plus that goes up to four pluses so this
is a PA plus plus plus plus and that is
the highest you can get for for like UVA
protection so it's just it's a much
better sunscreen and it just feels so
much better and I think like you know in
the u.s. it's not as much now like
people I feel like aren't tanning as
much if they do it's like fake tan but
people don't like prioritize staying
like yeah everyone wants to be tan but
in other countries a lot of people want
to be fair and so there's a lot more
like marketing and like development
money put into sunscreen and so it's
just better so even though this one's a
it's Japanese and origin you can get on
Amazon Prime the one I use is the B or a
watery gel PA plus plus plus plus SPF 50
will save all the details for the blog
post
Hey step down from her I'm sorry
basically how about this the sunscreen
will change your life feels better and
works better yeah yeah that's a good way
to summarize it up yeah everyone should
be wearing sunscreen all right
IIIi can't say that cuz I'd be a
hypocrite who's trying to convert we
just don't go out of the house much we
just kind of stay inside just if you're
driving to lunch yeah you should have it
on okay
ready for a new one yes do you not want
to die our tables ruining your life do
you wanna be an organizational God make
sure to use that specific line wait let
me guess
the velcro yeah yeah they're so good I'm
gonna look up the exact term reusable
thin ties basically it's like a dual
sided velcro and then this is a great
stocking stuffer and you should get this
for everyone get like a mega pack and I
think that it comes with like three
stacks the one that I'm going to link to
is there's like three sacks you can
divide it up into three different
stalking this keep one for yourself just
give two away I don't know but this is
gonna change your life every single one
of our cables all around the house
everywhere everywhere every single type
has one of these thin ties attached to
it whether it's extended or wrapped up
and basically what you do is you just
install this on every single cable and
when you wrap it up
you take that tie that's already on that
cable and then you just organize it and
it's it's it's so amazing I use twist
ties but then you take it off and it
gets lost you're like they get worn down
and they snap this is the best way to
use it I found find the plug that plugs
into the wall or like that whatever the
cable plugs into USB and wrap it like a
single wrap around the cable itself and
then when you bundle it up then you take
that excess and wrap it around the rest
and then that have like one attachment
point
where you can like loop it through
itself and it will like attached to the
cable but then you wrap it around excess
cable yes that way when you undo the
wrap it's still attached and then like
if you want to you can just wrap it up
around that single pass for storage mode
and then when you wrap it up again you
can undo it and resume your your cables
organized again they're so good we've
just recently like used up the last of
our mega mega mega roll and had to buy
one like our mega mega mega roll has
lasted us two years of like having an
extension of cables like our podcast
desk Oliver Li we have three desks all
organized with these cables our workshop
is organized with these cables they're
just there a 1k their life changing but
they're kind of life changing see
several just like from where I'm sitting
now yeah I can see at least five that's
a really good stocking stuffer such a
good stocking stuffer okay
what's yours do you want to save the
environment do you want to also still be
able to use a straw because you like
straws do you always want a cold
beverage good yeah with the strong lead
they don't come with a straw is like by
default get the ones with the straw lid
life-changing it's like we visited I'm
not gonna call anyone out but we visited
a maker friend who didn't know what
yetis were and we were like wait what I
thought that term a dual wall insulated
stainless steel vacuum cup one that you
can get a strong lid with specifically
yeah specifically with a strong like in
Texas every single person in our family
has it may not be Yeti brand but like a
version yeah of it that's like their cup
and that's like the one cup you use and
everyone has it cuz this is the cup I
drink out of every single day of my life
pretty much it's like it's like I only
have one cup and it's cuz maybe it's
cause like in Texas especially if you're
taking in the cars you the yetis are the
only thing that like it can be
90 degrees outside your car car for
hours it'll still have ice it's amazing
it's amazing so how it works is it's
stainless steel and there's a very
bottom there's a one-way valve that they
pull a vacuum on and that vacuum between
these two thin stainless walls doesn't
transmit heat because you need particles
to balance into each other to transfer
that heat so a vacuum is a really good
insulator and I just love staying the
seal because like it's it's so durable
it's very easy to clean and specifically
straws yeah it's so great I don't know I
think it's awesome yeah often times I
think because you know environmentalism
is taking root people are our cups and a
restaurant sit down restaurants where
they're gonna bring you a glass cup but
some things are going to like a faster
type food place or pulley or something
like I'm gonna bring the cup and nobody
cares cause like oh they don't have to
give you a water cup yeah and we don't
waste their resources and we don't
pollute there's better than anything
else out there
yeah I thought everyone liked having I
almost like didn't even I thought of
like recommending a dual wall vacuum
insulated stainless steel cup but I
forgot that some people don't know it
yeah I think I think two of our co.labs
cuz we bring the cups when we do coop oh
you're bring the cups when we travel we
would pack them in our bags we pack them
in our bags but I think two of our
co.labs that people we were coke Cola
because I didn't have them and didn't
use it and we were like what and we can
heard of them we can fry to them yes
yeah you should sponsor us do you wait
what did I go last okay do you want to
be a wise sage do you want to be able to
reverse engineer anything do you want to
know the length of things anytime no I
know what it is get a
a measuring tape that was on my list -
this is great stocking stuffer we have
these little tight that are the 8-foot
no out actually they just go to those
yeah because like they're they're not
the best for ordering online honestly
because they're so small they're so
cheap
that behind them online they're actually
more expensive just go to Lowe's and
find the smallest measuring tape you can
nine-foot is good six-foot is fine but
just like really like the smallest
measuring tape you can and get six of
them yeah you get them for like three
for you some for your stocking stuffers
like four and they just float around
around and grab them they're great to
like throw in your purse throw in your
pocket if you're going somewhere they're
gonna go shopping if you're looking for
like specific material oh you're just
like furniture shopping and you're like
oh I have a space where I need like a
nine inch by 12 inch basket you know and
you go to the store you can just measure
the baskets you know yeah it's just so
good it's so good or like when we're
around the house and honestly even
around the workshop just keep it in your
pocket while you're making and then use
that because there's very rare you need
a measuring tape longer than nine feet
yeah and they're so tiny they weigh like
nothing and they're maybe like an inch
and a half by an inch and a half
little round discs yeah my favorite I
think has a magnet in the center also
just you can slap it to stuff yeah we
only had one of those and it's kind of
in the cat dimension right now disappear
am i kicking myself that I didn't get
like eight of those yeah I didn't that's
the very first one we got I loved it
yeah we have the okay ones for now I'll
grab them over the big ones just cuz
they're so lightweight yeah come on
keychains metal piece of tape yeah yeah
yeah it's like the same thing is just
lighter weight and tinier sock more
suffer okay do you wanna live like a
hermit
are you tired of talking to the outside
world
are you also paranoid get a video
doorbell class shouting get a Google hub
our little scream oh but you need to let
me play in the background the Google hub
is a Google smart hub thing tiny scream
scream it's like a smart thing and you
can connect it to a whole bunch advices
you can control lights with it you can
control a whole bunch of different
things but how we have it hooked up is
we haven't hooked up to our doorbell so
when people come ring our doorbell like
we're in our office and they show up on
the screen automatically lights up and
shows the doorbell camera when someone's
at the front door so we don't have to go
out there and then acknowledge that we
are home which when you work from home
and you're home all the time if it's so
great and like you can send pre-recorded
responses so it's like a robot so you
don't have to show you're there or you
can answer remotely let's say you're out
at lunch and someone's ringing the
doorbell and sometimes we may not
realize that like a package is here but
it'll are a little thing will light up
and we're like oh so just dropped off
the package yeah you know so we'll go
grab it the combination is is pretty
powerful I would say like if you're
gonna get a video doorbell you should
get the hub you should gonna help you
you should get a video doorbell that
connects with a smart display in your
house too
so I will pull into this specific
combination that we have you can do your
research to see what ties into your
smart home if you're building up your
own but the combo of those two is really
nice okay let's see what I got
do you want to feel powerful do you want
ultimate flexibility I want to do one
more power and you also want to be an
organizational God let me think let me
think
power flexibility organization an
organizational guide think about power
in a very literal sense like strength no
no like that look just see power okay so
powerful so it has something to do with
power power electricity
yeah with electricity flexibility and
organizational the flexibility is timing
locational flexibility so it's like when
I think of electrical power and location
flexibility I think cordless but I don't
understand how it's cord Oh
it's corded yeah it's it is a cord it is
a cord it's an extension cord yeah kinda
the real yeah get a retractable
extension cord real they're so great we
flew in the workshop I know what you
need is you need the one that like
Rian's the cable as it goes in she
doesn't get tangled so you just like
release it and it winds it left to right
back and forth properly you really want
that feature you don't want one where it
just gets sucked up into this void and
it gets tangled so you need to get the
right one
so that you don't get really frustrated
with it but basically what you do is you
find an outlet in your garage you plug
this in and then you can pull it out use
it to power whatever you need and then
you retract it back in and I think that
this is a great thing for anyone that
has a garage yeah it doesn't just have
to be like if you're making stuff in the
garage
no like if you're blowing leaves in the
front yard if you're like doing like
everyone needs power in their garage at
some point for something and it's having
an extension cord that goes in and out
of a real is so great we have to I'm
thinking we might need three like one
like right behind us you know whenever
kind of cool
Oh thinking maybe like in a cabinet so
you open up the cabinet and pull it out
no but then like you have a open cabinet
in the background mm-hmm that's gonna be
pretty what if we put it above us what
if we drill a hole in the bottom and it
comes out that hole and we put a anyway
well figure it out we'll figure it out
later but like it's it's great it's
great and I highly recommend it now it
makes sense your clues that wasn't it
was kind of hard to guess yeah I tried
I'm trying to make a little bit harder
you try to be more obscure too because
we've been giving them to we've been
getting it too easy yeah
we've really been sucking at giving
clues my first day do you wanna be a
fashion guru do you wanna feel good
about what your money is supporting kids
uh team trees do you make things and
sometimes fail and sometimes make again
[Laughter]
because when this is coming out you
should probably if you want anything
from our store you should probably order
soon yeah print-on-demand
yeah we actually we want to do post
about it so I thought I'd bring it up
podcast cuz a lot of people will buy our
merch as gifts but when it's something
like the holidays the printing company
company we use there they don't just
print stuff for us it's like a big
company and everyone gets busy around
the holidays and it's all print on
demand so there
not like a stock so if you want any
merch before Christmas you should order
it as soon as possible and there's a
reason we've touched on a few times the
reason why we do print on demand for now
so that we can have a broad variety of
design sizes and men's and female and
kids colors different colors designs if
we if we did it the more like oh and
obviously it would make a lot more money
per t-shirt if we like just bought them
in bulk and sold them won t shirt unisex
one color we can't choose a single
design and we want everyone to be able
to give the shirt that they want and the
size they want so so that means the
printing is a little bit slower and it
means we make a lot less money but I
think it's the best for now get bigger
it would make more sense to we'll figure
out some other sort of solution which is
yeah different anyways for now order far
in advance so that you get it in time
yeah so you're not like printing out a
picture of the shirt that you bought and
giving them the picture coming in time
so here's a printout of what I bought
you give it to in a month next time I
see you my turn right yeah do you want
to be a kitchen God do you want to clean
things really easily
do you like multifunction tools get a is
it the set of silicone things is it the
pressure cooker what the cleaning thing
good a silicone spoon Salah okay yeah
the set of silicone tools like a
multi-purpose I thought you meant maybe
like the set of them ah I was thinking
like is a spoon shala is a star anise
for those of you don't know what a spoon
shil is it's a spatula and a spoon I
think 2001 we tried to not like just
repeat all of our thing of the week we
can't
one gonna get it for your mom get it for
yourself get it for your your color
friend anyone in your life that cooks
get it for them and even if they don't
get it for them and maybe they'll start
cooking yeah it's like we have a whole
set of tools that we like but the spoon
is the best it's a life-changing tool if
you cook a lot because that's going to
be the only tool you use for 90% of the
meals we use it like anytime we cook
we're using the spoon schlock and the
one that we always recommend people that
we use and have a few of it's like a
full silicone like single injection
molded body so there's no like cracks
and crevices for food to get in it's all
high-temperature rated so like it's not
got the handles I'm gonna melt if you
rest on the side amazing lasts for a lot
it has a long lifetime it's just I love
spoon great invention yeah so that's
something like if we do a gift guide
next year we'll probably our last gift
guide it probably wasn't our last we've
had and it was a thing of the week yeah
sorry messing with my mic super loose
there yeah okay thank you I just can't
touch it okay my job yeah do you want a
type with the proficiency of Russian
hacker did you want your keyboard to
withstand a nuclear do you want to
appreciate art in your everyday life
good resin keycaps
I thought you're going down the
mechanical reward keyboard thing of the
week and I was trying to avoid
this is more of a like gifty yeah so
first off you need a mechanical keyboard
to take advantage of this you do you do
but if you have someone that would
appreciate this they probably already
have a mechanical keyboard yeah it's
like a whole there's a whole rabbit hole
you
we I have one resin key cap that Evan
got me for my birthday
Evan has one on the way that has not
arrived yet and we because I really like
the specific artist yeah but it's like
these these handmade little resin
creations and the shape of keys that you
can you can swap with your mechanical
keyboard keys and they're just so
beautiful I have a little they're a
little like forest sprites from you know
sake films and Evans getting one that
has like koi fish yeah it's like a work
of art there's so pretty because like
like they feel so nice on your fingers
so many people sit in front of keyboards
a lot and I think that having like a
piece of art inside of your keyboard
that is your keyboard especially lights
up oh it looks like well I'm looking at
my boy like I think I think it's gonna
be like calming for me yeah like
whenever I look at my keyboard on a bit
oh look at those koi fish it's gonna be
I know it's gonna make me happy so
happen they're kind of expensive they
are expensive but it's also like enough
I mean what is the artist you found
though that both ours were from I got
yours from an Etsy seller oh it's a
different one okay yeah and mine is from
I think it's like my jelly or jelly to
the shops and so there's like different
drops so it's not something that's on
sale constantly because they'll make a
batch yeah so like four to five times a
year they'll announce what the design is
people can buy it and then they'll make
that design over the next two months so
it's like a long process but there might
be some like that's for like the job at
CSC there are some you can buy fairly
quick and they're maybe they're pretty
made yeah but yeah so we'll link to the
jelly keys that yours is coming from and
we can link to the Etsy shop that way
that's fine and we we've said that we're
gonna make a video on making their own
way all right half a year yeah and we
might one day but for now but for now I
think it's a good gift it's cuz it's
definitely like a hashtag treat yo'self
kind of thing so treat yourself they are
a little pricey
yeah you know I think they're totally
worth it obviously
we each have one but I think it's a
really cool gift and I think it's so
cool because even if someone has a
mechanical keyboard and they have their
own key caps it's fun to switch them out
yeah you know and the most common keys
to do our like spacebar escape enter
shift yeah ctrl alt yeah you don't
typically I don't really see it often
for like letter keys because you want to
see the letter some people do WASD I
could more arrows like special keys yeah
and and we can link to the mechanical
keyboards we have I think we've linked
to them before but just if you want to
make it a full package again they're a
little bit more expensive and we have
like a slightly more economical both of
them and then we have like the fuller
fuller one like the one that like it's
built like a tank
and it's very heavy yeah thank you are
we gonna oh yeah I was gonna say are we
not gonna do think of the weeks those
whole things I think yeah we all look at
their video their video yeah mindset
Instagram anyways
do you like hugs yes
did you always want to be wrapped in a
cozy blanket yeah do your feet get cold
get fuzzy socks I'm wearing them right
now I have links to these two sets
family to yours and I've linked to mine
mine are leopard print multi color and
Evans are black classic
no I I have a confession to make I hate
socks I've been hey
I hate socks I hate close toed shoes I
want to be a free child wearing
flip-flops or barefoot or barefoot for
my entire life but the reality is it
gets cold in winter and your feet have
sucky circulation you know and your feet
get cold and there's a thing called
fuzzy socks
and they're just like a magical thing I
don't I don't know how I can fully
explain it until you just wear it
yourself but socks compress my feet I
hate it
they're too tight there they bother me
they like like they make me a little bit
angry I'm a pretty happy guy my socks
angry and like I used to sometimes like
I would legit when I was when I had to
go to work and I had to wear socks for
nine hours a day or ten or for a long
period of the day out sometimes bring
flip-flops in the car with me as soon as
I hop in the car I would take off those
Kirsten socks okay yeah drive home
barefoot and then I put on flip-flops to
walk into the house yeah that's how much
I hate socks
I love fuzzy socks yeah for some reason
they are looser but they're also softer
they're stretchy er yeah they're so cool
they're like a blanket that's giving
your feet a hug here's another
confession so most people wear fuzzy
socks like just around the house in our
shoes out and about what about people
have seen us wearing fuzzy socks yeah
like you'll just wear me a tennis shoes
I usually wear mine with my boots but
I've worn with my tennis shoes and I've
worn them with my like flip-flop my my
slides a lot they work as socks yeah
they're just better look they look a
little bit fuzzy black yeah they're not
too bad but like fuzzy socks are better
than regular socks in every single way
yeah great great holiday oh my gosh and
socks are a traditional holiday gift and
oh my gosh it's cold yes perfect during
Christmas it's perfect upgrade someone's
life people people are you a messy
person yes do you like to express
yourself with art resin wood stains or
other messy things yes do you like to
roll the way your troubles and never
have to clean get Susilo phone
we knew it it was like we synced up we
think that but so these you guys are
probably seen in basically every one of
our videos
80% yeah we have these blue silicon
project mats and we keep we have like
four of them and we just keep it a roll
in the cabinets behind us and they're
the best freaking things to use them
with everything doing resin would stain
finish painting anything everything
protect your workbench and and stuff
like pops right off of them and then
like if they get too messy you can like
hose them down or we've like poured
extra resin sure wash them your pressure
washer they're really tough yeah we get
questions about them a lot and I always
link all right try to remember to always
link to them in our like project thingy
but you can get the smaller ones you can
get on Amazon the bear ones they're
Rockler brand so I think you have to get
the bigger ones on their website yeah I
wish I'd just put them on Amazon I know
but we'll link to we can link to both
yeah because they're both super awesome
and the big ones like interlocked so you
can make it like if you are a crafter if
you are any sort of major
like if you have kids and your kids are
doing projects and you want to like put
a mat down you don't have to use like
the crunchy like placemats I don't know
if people still are tablecloths yeah
that's like I don't know if people still
do that kid parties where they're just
be like the crunchy reusable oh yeah
yeah yeah do you want to use futuristic
tech do you dislike holes in your body
[Laughter]
do you want to heal like you have
regenerative powers get hydrocele
band-aids oh I was so lost until the end
I think you might have picked these
before but you've been using them lately
after an axe I'm preaching them I want
to reach out to band-aid and see if
they're gonna make they could sponsor me
or some band-aids it's like me with my
sunscreen yeah it's like guys as a human
being you're at some point gonna injure
yourself and when you do you want to
heal it as cleanly and as safely and as
sanitary as you can normal band-aids are
open on the sides and you have like
slather that cream on there and like
they're uncomfortable place the band-aid
like three times a day sometimes and
also whenever you shower they get messed
up whenever you're doing anything the
workshop they get messed up like normal
band-aids the kind of suck the kind of
suck yeah I gotta say like normal stick
on bandages yes is there like a brand
you know this hydrocele is amazing it's
like a artificial skin you put on over
your skin it keeps out all the bad
bacteria your skin does its own healing
process magic you can take showers in
them they last days like like they're
meant for to last for multiple days me
as like a maker in the workshop all the
time doing painting doing all that stuff
like it'll last on my hand like days
like showering every night it's
ridiculous how good these things are
they're fully sealed around the whole
thing you don't have to put like
antibacterial cream and I think one of
the best things about that is they don't
bother your hand like they're much more
flexible they're cushioned there's a lot
of different great aspects to them and
it totally feels like you're using some
futuristic tack yeah kind of a weird
present I don't know like honestly if I
had a maker in my life that I knew
didn't have these band-aids I'd get it
for them cuz that's true I think
especially for like a maker cuz like
it's it's it's so much better it's like
things things I want for Christmas
presents are like thoughtful gifts from
other people who know me who know what I
want that know things that I might not
know if I didn't know about these
band-aids and I got these band-aids and
I used them I'd be like oh my gosh that
person who got me this so thought my
life they knew exactly what I wanted and
I didn't even know that I wanted that I
think that's kind of like the gifts like
show that someone really thinks and
cares that's Joe you know it's like when
your brother and sister-in-law got us
that instant pot yeah like that changed
our lives it's like oh we should put
that on our list here I don't gift guide
lists be like being under pressure
do you like cheating at life get an
incident I know that everyone's saying
getting in spot it's like a very common
like they're so good basically it's a
way to cook things under pressure it
splits really automatic is really like
slow cooking but way faster but way
faster and safer pressure cookers yeah
Auto everything cuz that's busy people I
think the most efficient thing for us to
do is cook a big pot of delicious things
that's like very wet like there's a lot
of moisture in it we eat it once or
twice and then we freeze it and
individually we like make note of how
much with evident Caitlin yeah we we
make note of how much we ate each time
we ate it and then we put that exact
amount into freezer bags and we store it
and then we do another recipe another
has to be all like in this pressure
cooker and then we're like you know I'm
a little bit like I want to eat
something home-cooked and fresh but
I cook it from scratch let's put open up
the freezer drawer have you no frozen
stew or like frozen a sauce pasta sauces
soups stews chilies we do curry we do
like chicken tikka masala tons of
different varieties a lot of taco like
taco fillings like oh yeah like shredded
meats or you go vegetarian with like
bean dishes and stuff it's so useful and
for anyone who doesn't have time in life
to like cook elaborate things
this lets you like cook fancy things but
a lot faster and a lot easier because
he's kind of chop it all up toss it in a
bun bingo-bango been there done yeah all
right I think we I think we both have
some additional items on our list but
since we're getting tight on time
they'll include them in the in the blog
and the blog post
Kevin in Kaitlyn calm and well it'll be
there
it'll be podcast the podcast number Oh
for 6 or or this in the Lincoln
description of the week
my thing of the week is making perfect
which is a bone Appetit series its
season 2 the Thanksgiving season I said
that in a weird way like a weird order
but basically bone Appetit for those of
you who aren't familiar it's a magazine
but they also have a youtube channel
a really big fan of how a corporate and
a company like that is approaching
YouTube in general they give their their
on-screen personalities a lot of space
and they give their creative teams a lot
of flexibility to make fun content
that's like really genuine in the moment
and its really great but anyways and
they're making perfect season they take
a meal they take a dish and they explore
all of the different options so for
example Thanksgiving season 2 which is
the thing we're talking about episode 1
is turkey say like okay what's the best
way to cook a turkey is it to do you
roast it do you smoke it do you fry it
what's the best type of marinade or you
know what's the type of best type of
seasonings to put on it what's the best
like like everything every aspect of a
turkey how to cook it did you cook it
whole or in parts all of that they test
it all out in a very methodical way to
get the airport best version of that
meat that dish and every episode / like
food type that they're figuring out is
different people from the team um so
might be one person it might be like a
pair of people on that particular item
and then they bring it all together at
the end and like share with each other
I'm really excited to see what the
mashed potatoes turn out like potatoes
or mashed potatoes because they're like
well they need a potato dish and they
compare like mashed potatoes to other
types of potatoes
what if mashed potatoes doesn't win and
they're wrong and I don't know what to
do
wait and see it's already out we just
haven't watched all right yeah so I'm
excited okay and my thing of the week it
is I mean we follow them on Instagram
but they might have other stuff too like
yeah but it's Catana
comics I'm saying that right I'm not
like missing a syllable
yeah Catana comics so it's this
Instagram account and I I think it's the
girl and yes the girl in the
relationship that is the artist
and it's just these cute little like
illus comic illustrations of moments of
their life and I basically replace them
with us yeah you could basically replace
them with us like and I'm sure that
that's that's why they're so popular
because people like see themselves in
the comics but it's just really cute
little things are you pulling I just
can't I just can't like avoid clicking
on it because it's so cute yeah she's
Catana comics on instagram Catana with a
cape with SC it's just like you know
sometimes like the world is a scary
place and bad things might happen and
you just need a little dose of wholesome
happiness in your life and you're just
scrolling the Instagram you see one of
their comics and you're like oh yeah
they're super cute like they're so up
the last one and it's you see her kind
of like sneaking up on him she's gonna
give him a hug and then she's like
hopping up on his back and then she's
like fully just latched herself onto his
back he's on her front he's on his phone
and she's just like hi yeah I do that to
you I just like like jump on you yeah
it's just super cute very wholesome yeah
Kitana comics it's a little dose of
happiness in your life I love it when
there's a new one that pops up in it and
thus concludes the official gift guide
or unofficial that gives guys 2019 I
well I know this was a little bit
different but it's fun to keep on
experimenting with different types of
formats for podcasts know if you guys
like this cuz do random episodes that
are just things that we like finally
we've gotten requests to do like our
favorite movies TV shows yeah like our
favorite books family I guess though
because like we read different books how
would I guess yours we could come up
with a different format for the game oh
yeah yeah for yeah I know yeah you could
say a title it and I wouldn't oh come up
come up like I say the title and you
like
what is in your head and I'll correct
you and then you'll say a title all
describe what I think it is and then you
can correct me yes yes okay well I'm out
of words
we appreciate good ratings and reviews
we appreciate it if if you're watching
on YouTube if you like this video
sharing sharing our podcast around I
think that might be one of the best way
is to help out yeah there's still a lot
of people even though watch the main
videos I don't know we have a podcast
even though we like pin it in every
single video but yeah so we appreciate
you guys for listening and have a good
Thanksgiving if you celebrate
Thanksgiving yeah
[Music]